[音楽]
voodoo
[拍手]
皆さん
どうやったら面白い街が作れるのか
考えたり試したりした事ってありますか
僕は日頃建築デザイン事務所3人でやっています
建築という分野では
建物が建つ敷地の周辺環境にも目を向け
建物を設計する必要があります
そういった周辺に対する興味から業務とは別に
街に関わる活動を始めました
その活動について話しできればと思います
7年半前
僕は
地方の中堅都市であるここ浜松の街中に
移り住みました
生活圏で言えばさらに小さく
自宅から半径約500m くらいのハイんです
正直言うとそれ以外の地域では
チネを言われてもなんとなく方角がわかるくらいで
距離感を未だに掴めていません
なので
この半径500メートルの範囲を街として捉え
活動しています
街に言うと
昔に比べて浜松まちなかは寂しくなった
シワシワこういう意見を聞きます
皆さんどう思いますか
寂しい
つまらないと思う方
ございますしかしこういった意見を聴くたびに
そうかな結構面白い街じゃないかなと思っています
確かに90年代前半までは駅の周辺にたくさんの大型商業施設があり
中心地では通行人の方がぶつかり合うほどで
お店の人もトイレに行くのを我慢していたと聞きます
今では考えられない状況です
でも
こういった商業的経済的な発展だけではない
面白さや価値が街にはあるのではないでしょうか
街を作るためには何が必要でしょうか
すぐに思いつくのは建物や道といったハードウェアです
世界各地で新しい場所
古い場所彼等は異なりますが
頭と下建物や未知なることから考えると
ハードウェアが街を作るために重要な要素だということは明らかです
僕の一号の仕事もそんな街のハードに関わる仕事です
街中では小さな球形ブースや
店舗や住居などその規模は様々ですが
手がけているプロジェクトは約15に登ります
今では
見学に来た方にプロジェクトを紹介するときはちょっとした
街中の散策のようになります
例えば
通常健在ではない帯状のブラインドカーテンを壁に持
キッチンと倉庫の拡張を行ったお蕎麦屋さんでご飯を食べ
その後昔をなさんが使っていた木造のロフトの部材を
転用した4室の休憩小屋や
同じビルの1階にある積層ダンボールを
什器として使った眼鏡屋さんを案内します
また別のビルに移動すると
店主の働く姿がショーウィンドウとなる
アパレルショップや
店舗の光環境と商品時スペのために
間接光を使った陶器屋さんを見て回ることができます
こういった街中のプロジェクトに共通する特徴の一つは
少し古い建物に対して
材料や建物の特性を考慮しながら利用し
新しい空間を生み出すことです
[音楽]
皆さんもイノベーションという言葉をご存知かと思いますが
近年ではこういった古い建物が味があるものとして見直されています
浜松の街中の建物も
現在ではできないような
せ仕事の美しさや
個人の店として使うのにちょうどいい
規模化の
ハードとして多くの美点があります
そして
紹介ツアーを終えて参加者に感想かだと
オーナーさんの空間の使い方や
僕たちとオーナーさんの関係性の近さがとても良かったと言っていただけます
僕たちの作品自体を褒めていただいているのかなっていう気はしますけどポジティブに
解釈すると
僕たちが作ったハードウェアがものや
人の関係をイキイキさせていると言っていただいているんだと思っています
僕の解釈は
さておき
これらの感想が示していることは
使い方はとても重要だということです
どんなに建築つまりハードウェアも
使う人がいなければ
廃墟になってしまいます
反対に
地域とした使い方をされることで
これまで見向きもされなかったような建物や場所が
実はとてももしでもいいということに気付くことさえあります
そこで
街の使い方を考えということをテーマに活動しています
活動を通して
街にかかっている人は二つの立場を持っていると感じています
一つ目は
使い手
プレイヤーとしての立場です
もう一つは
使いて応援するサポーターとしての立場です
僕の活動も同様に二つの立場を持っています
ここで
そのそれぞれの立場で行ったプロジェクトを2つご紹介したいと思います
まずはプレイヤーとしての活動です
これは上野智子さんと共同で企画したパーキングというプロジェクトです
このプロジェクトでは街中の平面駐車場に着目しています
全国の地方都市で
家が市の建物が取り壊されると
その多くの土地が駐車場となります
泡沫の街中も例外ではありません
駐車場自体
街の入り口となる必要なインフラなんですが
駐車されていない時は町にとって空き地のような存在になってしまっています
このパーキングというプロジェクトではその使われていない時間を利用してピクニック
してしまおうということを試みです
知人のお花屋さんにお花の移動販売をしてもらいながら
マークショップや
アーティストのトークイベントを企画して
駐車場でのんびり過ごします
街のもったいないと思われる場所を生き生きとした場所に変換する実験です
次にサポーターとしての活動です
これは晩年場所パークビューという立体駐車場の最上階部分です
年間を通して稼働率が低かったこの空間をフリースペースのような形で使いたいとお話
をいただいて僕が運営しています
当初はもっとは駐車場ですし何ができるんだろう
いう感じでした
ただ
体育館
いやホールといった特定の目的でしか利用できない場所ではなく
容赦さんが使い方を身に出していけるような場所がいいと思って
運営は最低限に
日程の調整だけにと止めました
利用料金もありません
無料なので急にいろんなことが起こっても対処に困ると思って
口をやめて
商店街の関係者と知事にだけ伝えて使っていました
1年ぐらい経つと
徐々に人から人へと伝わったのか
知らない人からも連絡が来るようになるなりました
今では
近隣の商店主や学生が遊ぶために利用したり
講演会や
イラストレーターの展覧会
音楽イベントや
わるしな
としたような使われ方がされています
いろんなことが起こるようになって
さすがに内容によっては有料としましたが
上の仕方は今も大きくは変わっていません
これらの主体の方々は準備はもちろん
必要があれば近隣への挨拶や
イベントが重なった時の場所の調整などを当人同士てやっていただいてい
管理しすぎずに使いたいと言っていただいた方をできるだけ応援するっていうのは利用
者さんにとっても
実は上にとっても
手間がかかりますし時には問題が起こります
それでも
利用される方が上に関わることによって皆さんきっと自分たちの場所だと思って
いただいていると思っています
こんなことが起こるとは
最初に相談をくださったパークビルの社長さんは
想像と違ったと思っていると思います
でも
僕が上を託されていこうやり方を変えてとは言われていないので
きっと
駐車場の売り上げが伸びてそれに光景していると判断していただいているのだと思って
います
とても良い社長さんです
このように
mature 使い方を考えるということは建物をハードウェアとするとソフトウェア
を考えることといえます
新たなもしくは街にとって必要なソフトウェアを作ることで面白いことをやる人が
集まり
新たな人と人の関係をんでいます
この両輪が面白い街をつくっていくためにとても重要だと思っています
僕が最初に
派閥の街を結構面白い街じゃないかなと言った理由は
このハードウェアとソフトウェアがうまく影響しあって
経済的な価値だけではない価値が町に生まれていて
しかもそのいい状態が自発的に継続されていると思っているからです
言い方を変えると
今町にあるものの良さを発見しながら
これまでにない試みで活用できる場所
そしてそれらを応援する土壌がある
それが浜松の街ということです
こう考えるとこのいいサイクルは浜松だけではなくほかの街でも作ることができるかも
しれません
でもで貨物
この街の価値を育てていくことでさらに面白い街へと
成長できるのでではないかと思っています
もちろんこれは僕一人だけでできることではありません
今浜松町に住んでいる
訪れる人がこの街の良さに触れて
価値観が共有されることで広がっていくことだと思っています
僕が浜松に来た当時に比べてすでに面白くなっています
皆さん最近浜松の街中に遊びにきたことってありますか
もう白くなっていく街をぜひ覗きに来てください
[拍手]